Guten Morgen Dietrich. Guten Morgen Tim.
Ist gerade nicht so die Zeit für Witze, oder?
Absolut nicht. Don't Menschen the Wahl.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer einhundertsechsundneunzig on the Road two two Handrid. Fünfer.
Hundertsechsundneunzig ist eine Brückentechnologie.
Ja, ein Migrationspfad zu ähm unserem Event, den wir angekündigt haben mit breiter Brust.
Und der jetzt auch stattfinden wird. Der Wehet statt.
Ja, jetzt müssen, jetzt müssen, müssen wir liefern, ja. Ist aber noch nicht alles äh noch nicht alles, äh, könnte verraten werden an diesem Zeitpunkt.
Genau, wir müssen das ja auch ein bisschen spannend machen und geheime Andeutung. Was geht hier auch so ein bisschen so Cliffhänger zu haben so, ne? Das man so am Ende der Sendung diese okay krass, jetzt weiß ich schon mal das Datum, aber wo ist das?
Mythenbildung.
Genau Mythenbildung, so. Also ein Lockbuch Netz für Tick zweihundert wird kommen.
Es wird am neunundzwanzigsten zehnten sein, könnte man sagen.
Könnte man sagen, ja.
Was man könnte sich vorstellen, dass das so in Berlin.
Das ist sehr wahrscheinlich.
Sofern Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg jetzt nicht noch aus Berlin auszieht bis dahin und sich irgendwie in der Nähe eines Flughafens neu aufbaut oder so.
A oder sich einen eigenen zulegt. Ja ähm das ist vermutlich äh der Ort, mit dem man äh von dem man ausgehen kann, ja.
Wir wollen unsere Verhandlungsposition mit den Veranstaltern an dieser Stelle nicht schwächen. Wir versuchen da gerade das Olympiastadion gegen die O2-World auszuspielen. Insofern können wir da jetzt noch uns noch nicht festlegen.
Ja
Ja, das geht natürlich äh hier um einfach nur um harte Kohle,
mit der wir da in die Verhandlung treten müssen,
und äh deswegen wollen wir hier unsere Verhandlungsposition nicht schwächen aber unsere Chefunterhändler haben uns gesagt so es sieht nach Berlin aus. Wir haben einfach bellen. Die Stadt Berlin hat uns schon das beste Angebot gemacht. Kann man an der Stelle sagen.
Ja, also es äh so wird es sein.
Die haben ja vor ein paar Jahren den Congress verloren und die wissen auch, dass sie das nicht nochmal wollen. So, das haben wir den mir so gesagt.
Genau, also für alle alle, die sich gefragt haben, an an welcher äh St
Berlins, der Mann sich den sozusagen am besten einquartieren sollte, um dort überschaubare Laufwege zu haben und auch noch in einem äh End
Anti-Nüchternzustand äh von der Veranstaltung äh äh sicher nach Hause zu kommen. Das wäre so in etwa die Koordinate, die ihr da anvisieren solltet.
Ansonsten fahren auch Shuttle-Limousinen vom Atlon. Weiß ich, also das Adlon hat gefragt, ob sie äh ja, also es wird, es wird ein ein Lokbuchnetz für Tick zweihundert wird kommen.
Ja, genau. Wir werden dann in den nächsten Wochen noch äh weitere Details äh abliefern. Ich hoffe, schon bald auch sehr viel genauere. Aber Dinge müssen vorbereitet werden. Ja, was denn sonst noch so passiert?
Mal wieder eine Reihe an äh an schönen Nachrichten, die einen, die einem Hoffnung machen. Ähm es geht los mit dem Fall von Lorry Love.
Den wir auch schon hätten viel, viel, viel früher mal erwähnen können, aber soweit ich weiß, noch kein einziges Mal hier auch nur erwähnt haben.
Nee, das stimmt nicht. Wir haben den glaube ich schon mal vor ein paar Jahren erwähnt, da ging es nämlich um die ja, um die Herausgabe sein der Passwörter seiner beschlagnahmten Geräte. Das.
Ach, das kann sein, dass wir das, dass wir das am Rande mal erwähnt haben, ja.
Also Lorry Love ist ein ähm ein Brite, aber auch ein Finner, doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft hält sich aber in Großbritannien auf,
Und äh wird seit zwanzig dreizehn von den USA beschuldigt, sich an der,
Operations Operation Lars Resort der des losen Hackerkollektivs äh Nonnemis beteiligt zu haben,
diese Operation Last Resort war Lose verbunden mit einer Rache für den Tod von Aaron Swats ähm den wir ja hier auch damals ausführlich behandelt haben,
kurz zusammengefasst, er hatte
Scientific Journals, gecrollt aus einem aus dem MIT wurde dann mit äh strafrechtlich verfolgt und belangt und mittrakonischen Strafen bedroht und äh so in,
den Suizid getrieben. Ähm eines der,
bitteren Opfer, die die Bewegung hinnehmen musste und das eben auch nicht hinnehmen wollte. Und da gab's, kam es dann eben unter anderem zu diesem Protesthacks ähm.
Lorry wird beschuldigt, die Federal Reserve, die US-Armee, die Mission Defense Agency und die NASA irgendwie gehackt zu haben,
Äh es gab dann die USA haben zwei ähm Expredition Reques quasi, also in den USA geht es darum, ihn zu.
Zu bekommen und in den in dem Vereinigten Königreich hat er keine offiziellen Anschulden, keine offiziellen Beschuldigungen. Trotzdem haben natürlich die Ermittlungsbehörden, dann ähm sind bei ihm eingeritten, haben,
Seine Geräte beschlagnahmt, da gab es dann ein ähm ein Gerichtsverfahren, wo sie versucht haben, ihn zu zwingen, die äh Passwörter,
herauszugehen zu seinen verschlüsselten Geräten, damit sie dort die Beweise ähm.
Erbringen können, dass die Geräte ihm auch gehörten, also es sei irgendwie so, das ist ja immer wie, wie dann in England äh argumentiert wird, ist ja auch wirklich ein großer Witz, dass sie wie sagten so, dass er sagt, ich hätte gerne meine Geräte wieder die aus meiner Wohnung geholt habe, dann haben die gesagt, na ja
solange die hier verschlüsselt sind, könnt, können wir ja nicht den Nachweis bekommen, dass sie auch wirklich dir gehören, deswegen können wir sie dir nicht wiedergeben, ne? Also
diesem Niveau muss wird dieser Mann jetzt irgendwie.
Fertig gemacht seit seit inzwischen auch drei Jahren. Äh zwanzig sechzehn äh kam dann das Urteil, dass er diese Passwörter nicht geben muss. Parallel gibt es eben dieses Auslieferungsverfahren,
Ähm wo es im Juni schon ähm Anhörungen gab. Bei diesen Anhörungen wurde dann eben,
hervorgebracht, dass Lory unter dem Asperger Syndrom leidet und dass ihm quasi in den USA kein faires,
äh Verfahren bevorsteht, dass wenn er dort verurteilt würde, ihm irgendwie bis zu neunundneunzig Jahre Haft drohen und die USA dafür bekannt sind, keine,
Akzeptablen Haftbedingungen für Menschen in seinem Zustand zu haben. Das könnte man jetzt mal ausschalten, das piepen, ne? Ähm.
Und da wurde also alles vorgebracht, um diesen Menschen davor zu schützen, in die USA ausgeliefert zu werden.
Nun gab es das Urteil. Im ich glaube am sechzehnten September,
und er wurde jetzt quasi dazu verurteilt, ähm dass er ausgeliefert werden soll in die USA. Er hat vierzehn Tage Zeit, um diese Entscheidung anzufechten.
Das wäre bis dreißigsten September und seinen Anwalt ähm hat auch angekündigt, dass sie das tun werden. Ähm.
Wir sehen ja, was in den USA so los ist mit Leuten, die irgendwie der.
Der Abtrünnigkeit äh beschuldigt werden und ich denke, das ist hier schon ein sehr klarer Fall, dass diesem,
dass egal was dieser Mensch getan hat, selbst wenn er schuldig ist, was er auch noch bei weitem nicht bewiesen ist, dass man sagen kann, dass ihm dort kein faires Verfahren.
Ähm entgegen gegenüber steht, da äh,
Die USA ja schon seit Jahren jetzt dafür bekannt sind, auch an an kleineren Fällen,
eben ein Exempel zu statuieren. Wir berichten ja hier schon regelmäßig über Chelsea Maning. Wir berichten hier regelmäßig über Adsnorden und wir berichten ja auch.
In gewissem Ausmaß regelmäßig über das Urteil von Julian Assange und man kann jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen, dass diesen Menschen ein,
Von Reife und Bedachtheitszeugen des rechtsstaatlichen Verfahren,
angeboten worden wäre, sondern es geht eher darum, an diesen Personen schreckliche Exempel zu statuieren und dieses äh dieses Schicksal droht nun leider auch,
Lorry Love, wir werden da weiter drüber berichten und ähm ja, hoffen, dass ihm da der Schutz zuteil.
Und Kimble. Und das auch.
Denn das wird eben auch als Strafe angedroht. Was? Lorry Love, Kimble, als Strafe?
Was?
Neunundneunzig Jahre Haft und Kimbel.
In der gleichen Zelle. Oder noch schlimmer. Mega Upload-Videos gucken müssen.
Ja. Also hier werden wir unter Umständen noch sehr kurzfristig sehr ausführliche Solidaritätsaktionen planen müssen, denn diese Auslieferung muss selbstverständlich verhindert werden.
Ja, müssen wir abwarten, was da jetzt als nächstes äh kommt. Ich schätze mal den Widerspruch wieder einlegen und dann.
Ja natürlich, also der wird.
Zieht sich das noch ein bisschen. So dann haben wir noch das schöne BND Gesetz, äh das kommt äh,
nicht nur weil Lokbuchnetzpolitik immer mehr in die Diskussion, also wir reden nicht von BND-Gesetz, wie es jetzt existiert seien, das BND-Gesetz für dessen
sogenannte Reform ist jetzt entsprechende Vorschläge gibt, die haben wir ja hier auch schon ausführlich besprochen, zuletzt hier auch nochmal mit André. Und jetzt Politik Ork,
Ja und jetzt äh hat man so den Eindruck, jetzt kommt das so ein bisschen in die Medien und wird äh auch von mehr und mehr Organisationen reflektiert und es steht eine öffentliche Anhörung an.
Ja und die, also dass wie das so ist, ne? Das wird ja dann irgendwann mal zügig die öffentliche Anhörung ist äh am Montag schon am sechsundzwanzigsten September. Ähm,
im Innenausschuss, da sind dann einige ähm Sachverständige geladen, die sich zu diesem.
Gesetz äußern werden. Ich kann aber ganz kurz schauen, wer das so ist. Es gibt eine Stellungnahme von Doktor Professor Doktor Klaus Ferdinand Gerditz von der Universität Bonn. Es gibt eine Stellungnahme von Doktor Kurt Graulich, dem Richter am Bundesverwaltungsgericht.
Der Mann aus dem Keller.
Genau, der Mann, der im Keller saß, dann Thorsten Wetzling von der Stiftung neue Verantwortung. Gerhard Schindler vom BND, das ist ja immer so eine der schönen äh eine dieser schönen Angelegenheiten bei diesen Anhörungen, ähm was sich ja auch immer
wenn ich dort zu Gast bin mit mit Interesse beobachte, dass die, die das Gesetz betreffen wird, denn da auch nochmal da sind, um zu sagen, ja, finden wir gut oder nicht. Ähm.
Erik Töpfer, deutsches Institut für Menschenrechte, Professor Doktor Heinrich Amadeus Wolf von der Universität Bayreuth, Rundfunkanstalten, Andrea Vosshoff, die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte,
Und äh der parlamentarische Beirat für nachhaltige Entwicklung. Das ist also eine größere Angelegenheit.
Und was dieses Gesetz ja tun wird, es gibt einen schönen Artikel auf Netzpolitik Orgreute, der nochmal kurz zusammenfasst, abhören darf der BND dann jetzt auch,
in Deutschland, das ist sehr interessant für einen Auslandsgeheimdienst in diesem Zusammenhang müssen wir eben auch die Klage äh,
äh Dezix sehen, über die wir letzte Woche schon berichtet haben, wo es eben genau um die diese Verletzungen geht. Ähm,
die zwanzig Prozent Hürde soll abgeschafft werden, dass so dass der BND auf einzelnen Leitungen inzwischen dann nicht mehr nur zwanzig Prozent, sondern einhundert Prozent abhören darf ähm
eine,
sehr große Ausweitung der Begründung der möglichen Begründungen für das Abhören. Das heißt, man hatte klar definierte Abhörziele wie Terrorangriffe oder sowas,
Mit diesem Gesetz sollen diese jetzt aufgeweicht werden, sodass sie also weniger gut greifbar sind und dass man quasi einfach die,
praktischen Hürden einfach sehr stark heruntersetzt durch Gummiparagraphen,
Die Metadaten sollen gespeichert und an die NSA weitergegeben werden dürfen.
Ja, ist schon geil.
Und ähm es soll noch mehr äh Gremien für die Kontrolle geben, statt einer besseren Kontrolle. Ähm im Moment,
Ob liegt die Kontrolle schon drei Gremien, die jeweils nur einen Ausschnitt sehen und dieses Gesetz soll eben ein viertes, unabhängiges Gremium schaffen,
Dass dann von der Bundesregierung ernannt wird, das heißt auch da das ist seit wir haben ja einen neuen Kontrolleur, den suchen wir uns selber aus. Auch das ist natürlich keine
Unabhängige, effektive Kontrolle, das heißt wir haben eine Reihe an Nebelkerzen und eine nachträgliche Legalisierung vieler der Praktiken, die gerade im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss harsche Kritik finden, um dieses dieser gesamte Skandal dreht und das ist natürlich die
absolut katastrophal, falscheste,
Konsequenz aus dieser ganzen Angelegenheit, die hier gezogen werden soll. Deswegen formiert sich der Protest. Es gibt eine Petition von Katharina Nokon, die ihr auch schon mal bei uns zu Gast war zu einem ganz anderen Thema. Ähm,
Petition hat den Titel, ich fordere sie auf, die neuen Überwachungsbefugnisse für den Bundesnachrichtendienst abzulehnen. Es wird am sechsundzwanzigsten neunten,
eine Protestkundgebung geben vor dem Reichstag äh Platz der Republik eins äh also da auf dieser Wiese. Hier wird das beschrieben als mit Blick auf den Schriftzug dem deutschen Volker, aber äh,
dass es halt diese Wiese, ne.
Dann gibt es von der digitalen Gesellschaft eine Telefonaktion mit einem kostenlosen Anruftool. Da geht man auf die ähm,
Auf die Seite sucht sich die die Abgeordnete Person seiner Wahl heraus und klickt auf Anrufen.
Und dann gibt man seine eigene Telefonnummer ein und dann kriegt man einen Rückruf. Wenn man den annimmt, wird man automatisch damit verbunden, ja? Also quasi so ein, also du du sagst, ich möchte diese Person anrufen.
Genau. Und äh dann kann man dort mit den Abgeordneten sprechen, was sich ja immer mal wieder empfiehlt. Also das Entscheidende ist.
Es geht hier darum,
mehr oder weniger alles, worum sich dieser gesamte Skandal dreht, alle Rechtsverstöße, die es hier je gab, im nachträglich zu legalisieren und ich denke, das ist der absolut,
Die absolut falsche Konsequenz aus dem Skandal, den wir nun mehr seit drei Jahren hier behandeln.
Gulls aus.
Dann gab's noch sehr äh interessante Neuigkeiten aus dem Bereich des BND, wo man auch gar nicht so weiß, was da schon wieder los war. Ähm,
Wie ich ja gerade schon sagte, der BND ist der Auslandsgeheimdienst. Und wir haben ein hat in Deutschland eigentlich erstmal nichts verloren.
Und jetzt stellte sich heraus, er wurde irgendwie thematisiert, dass der BND Kurierdienstleistungen für mehrere Bundesbehörden und Ministerien erbringt,
Und das sowohl auf deutschem Boden als auch im Ausland.
Das ist natürlich ganz, also du musst dir quasi so vorstellen, du bist jetzt eine Bundesbehörde, möchtest irgendwie ein, ein Brief von äh A nach B bringen.
Und.
Sagen wir mal, das ist irgendwie, du brauchst vertrauenswürdige Personen, die das übermitteln und die Geheimnisse darin waren, dann denkst du natürlich als allererstes so die Vertrauenswilligste Instanz, der du deine Geheimdienstgeheime,
Geheimnisse anvertrauen kannst, ist natürlich der BND,
Ja, der BND ist natürlich klar, der hat noch nie ein Geheimnis verraten und es steht ja auch Nachrichtendienst dran. Das heißt, er kann ja ruhig mal Nachrichten übermitteln. Und jetzt fragt man sich natürlich.
The fuck. Ja, was macht dieser B, was erlaube BND auf deutschem Boden äh sich als Kurierdienstleister zu betätigen? Ähm.
Als Kunden wurden hier äh genannt, das Auswärtige Amt, das Bundesverteidigungsministerium, das Bundesamt für den Verfassungsschutz, das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik und der Bundesrechnungshof und dann,
Wir zeit sich darüber, wird halt darüber berichtet, dass die Kurierfahrten, die der BND vornimmt.
Teilweise mehrere Tage oder gar Wochen in Anspruch genommen hätten.
Tage und Wochen. Ja. Du meinst, die liegen noch hinter Hermes.
Die liegen hinter Hermes, ja. Weil es irgendwie einen Umweg über Pullach gibt. Und ich mein,
wenn dein wenn der Kurierdienstleister der Bundesnachrichtendienst ist, ja? Und du hast Verzögerungen in der in der Zustellung, der ihm anvertrauten Dokumente, dann sollte es schon mal nachfragen
Und das tun jetzt eben auch Parlamentarier,
Äh und äh da wird dann äh wird man sich jetzt fragen, ob die Bundesregierung denn nicht mal erklären könnte, warum die Kurierfahrerfahrten zwischen manchen Behörden teilweise so lange gedauert haben.
Und warum dieser BND hier überhaupt auf deutschem Boden aktiv ist? Ähm das scheint also hier äh,
Also es eigentlich eine äh Verletzung der des Aufgabenbereiches und Konstantin von Notz fragt natürlich auch, was genau passiert denn mit diesen Hochsensiblen,
Informationen, wenn der BND sie in die Hände bekommt. Und es ist natürlich schon sehr äh eine sehr interessante Auffassung von Geheimdienst,
oder Nachrichtendienst, wenn du denkst, das ist ein Kurier und bei dem werden irgendwie Geheimnisse sicher, ne? Also es ist äh schon,
Also du was? Wat erlaube BND.
Ja, das sind ja ist ja verschlossenes Kuriergut, äh hieß es da, da kann ja was kann da schon passieren, da ist ein Umschlag drum, ja,
Ich freue mich, ob die auch so Maschinen haben wie damals äh die Stasi für den Postweg noch nach Berlin beziehungsweise gar nicht mal nur, ich glaube es hat nicht die Westdeutschen auch solche.
Du meinst diese LKW-Anhänger, wo quasi die Post während der Fahrt über den äh über den heißen Wasserdampf gehalten aufgemacht und wieder.
Gab's das auch als LKW-Anhänger? Das ist mir neu, aber so als stationäres System äh auf jeden Fall. Das.
Ich meine, dass äh dass sogar irgendwie in Mobil gab, um halt die Verzögerung bei der Zustellung äh im Elverschaubaren Rahmen zu halten.
Ist die Frage, wie gut ist dieses Kurier gut verschlossen, ja? Ich meine, ist ja ein klassisches Verschlüsselungsproblem an der Stelle. Ähm tja.
Ja, aber wenn die E-Fahren gibt man das mal mit. Ja, über Pullach.
Wie fahrt ihr denn? Ja, über Pullach. Weißt du, von Berlin nach Hamburg über Pullach oder sowas, ne?
Ja, das ist halt so. Das ist echt geil.
Ja, das ist irgendwie durch eine über den Rechnungshof ist das irgendwie so ein bisschen herausgekommen.
Ich fände das eigentlich ganz interessant, ich werde hier jetzt auch mal anfragen, was das so kostet. Vielleicht kann ich ja auch mal bei dem.
Was transportieren lassen sozusagen?
Einfach mal eine Nachrichtendienstleistung.
Mhm.
Eine Bundesnachrichtendienstleistung.
So, die deutsche Cyberwehr hat äh zugeschlagen. Ja.
Oh, es ist endlich was verteidigt worden.
Auch hier mal wieder ganz spannend, ja? Wir haben ja äh erst kürzlich in den letzten Monaten die äh Bestrebungen,
dass die deutsche oder ne es gar nicht in den letzten Monaten, ich glaube da haben wir, hat Andre schon bei der LNP. War das eigentlich die LMP einhundert auf dem Camp?
Oder war das die LMP einhundertfünfzig?
Neunhundertfünfzig war auf dem letzten Camp. Ja. Mhm.
Ja, ne? Wenn die hundert war mit Ströbele, ne?
Die Hundert war mit Ströbler, die war im Bundestag.
Und die zweihundert, können wir noch gar nicht sagen, ne?
Ha ha!
Lustiges Spiel.
Na ja, bei unserem Output kann man auf jeden Fall äh in etwa so jedes anderthalb Jahr feiern. Also wir wir werden ja voraust hier so einen Schnitt von, was war das vierzig.
Vierzig pro Jahr.
Pro Jahr haben.
All zweieinhalb Jahre ungefähr.
Gar nicht so schlecht für.
Das wird doch, das wird noch.
Sendung, die den Anspruch hat, wöchentlich zu sein.
Was lassen wir das? Äh also wir wir die Special Guests von der Log Buchnetzkritik zweihundert äh werden noch nicht verraten. Ähm aber da berichtete Andre ja schon über die Bestrebungen,
von Ursula, von der Leyen wie wird hier nochmal immer genannt, der der etwas äh Tuppenursel ist ein bisschen äh.
Na ja, da gibt's so einen Twitter-Account.
Ach so, echt bisschen bisschen bisschen witzig.
Der ist ganz lustig.
Die Tropenursel äh hatte ja schon gesagt, wir machen jetzt hier Cyber und zwar nicht nur defensiv, sondern auch offensiv,
und jetzt wird hier erklärt, das ist halt, hat auch zwanzig fünfzehn schon stattgefunden. Und zwar.
Jedes Jahr hier die um die Einheit äh Computer, Netzwerkoperationen, CNO und die haben in Afghanistan einen Mobilfunkbetreiber gehackt, um dort.
Informationen über den Aufenthaltsort von Personen zu erlangen. Äh.
Die verdächtig waren im Zusammenhang mit der Entführung einer Entwicklungshelferin zu stehen.
Ähm bis heute war aber der offizielle Stand, dass man dort zwar unter Laborbedingungen, Cyberangriffe und Gegenattacken,
ausübt und eine Anfangsbefähigung für Attacken aufgebaut habe, aber eben nicht, dass diese Befähigung auch in der freien Wildbahn zum Einsatz kommt. Was hier passiert sein soll, ist zwanzig fünfzehn,
Im Herbst zweitausendfünfzehn, also ungefähr vor einem Jahr ähm wurde diese Einheit vom Krisenstab gebeten, der diesen Geiselfall der Entwicklungshelferin in Afghanistan betreute. Ähm.
Information,
ähm Informationen über die Entführer zu bekommen. Also die der Krisenstab war in Verhandlungen über die Freilastung der Entwicklungshelferinnen, die entführt worden waren.
Die hatten über Mittelst Männer einen Kontakt zu den Entführern und die Entführer haben gesagt, na ja, gegen Lösegeld lassen wir diese Person frei. Der Krisenstab wusste aber nicht, ob ähm,
den Entführern zu trauen sei, ob die zum Beispiel,
sich an diese Vereinbarung halten oder nicht und die wollten quasi wissen, bewegen die sich in die Richtung, ja, in die vereinbarte Richtung,
dass eine Übergabe stattfindet. Gleichzeitig hatten sie natürlich das Kommando Spezialkräfte irgendwie in der Hinterhand ähm die das notfalls dann gewaltsam, die äh die die Geisel befreien sollte,
Da ist man natürlich in einem Risikobereich. Jetzt haben sie gesagt, liebe äh CNO ähm bitte.
Ortet die Mobiltelefone der Entführer.
Und sagt uns, ob die sich in Kabul aufhalten, ob die sich im zum vereinbarten Zeitpunkt in Richtung des Übergabeortes bewegen oder nicht.
Die offizielle Geschichte, die jetzt veröffentlicht wird, ist, dass die CNO-Einheit,
über die im Internet verfügbare Kundenwebsite dieses Mobiltelefonanbieters.
Sich in dieses indessen System eingehakt hat und daraufhin durch das Netz, durch das Mobilfunknetz die Geopositionsdaten abgreifen konnte.
Und so dann mehr oder weniger live die Bewegungen der Kidnapper nachverfolgen konnte.
Jetzt habe ich mich ja so ein bisschen mit Mobilfunknetzen auseinandergesetzt und es ist auf jeden Fall also was geht, ist ganz klar, kommen wir auch gleich nochmal zu über ein Mobilfunknetz, kannst du problemlos den Aufenthaltsort einer Person bestimmen.
Wenn du entsprechenden Zugriff auf dieses Netz hast.
Wer nur in Schwäne Zugriff auf das Netz hast, dass du diesen Zugriff über das Mobilfunknetz erreichst, erlangst. Ähm halte ich für,
Mittelwahrscheinlich
Du würdest eigentlich diesen Zugriff auf andere Wege versuchen zu erlangen, sei es durch durch das Hacken von Administratoren,
aber das jetzt ausgerechnet eine Sicherheitslücke in dem Mobilfunkwebseite findest, die dir einen direkten Zugriff ermöglicht auf die Location-Daten des Mobilfunknetzes.
Klingt fischi.
Das klingt für mich ein bisschen unwahrscheinlich. Also solche Architekturen mag es geben,
Erhalte ich aber für, also hab ich so noch nicht gesehen, dass das jetzt ausgerechnet der Weg wäre, den eine,
Cyber, eine erfahrene Cybereinheit der Bundeswehr ausgerechnet gehen würde. Ja, also das, es gäbe.
Kenntnisse dadrüber, dass diese Architektur so vorliegt, aber ich denke, es ist halt auch sehr, also selbst in Afghanistan wahrscheinlich eher unwahrscheinlich, dass
solche Dienste zusammengelegt sind einfach, weil die,
organisatorisch und technisch wenig Gemeinhaben, also die Technik, die einfach ein Mobilfunknetz treibt, hat ganz andere Anforderungen an Standort und äh Laufzeitbedingungen und Betreuung und administrative Zugriff
als eine Webseite und klingt merkwürdig.
Der die einzige, die einzige Notwendigkeit der Verbindung da ist, ist es eigentlich das Billing, also alles, was du über die Webseite ähm.
Ändern und manipulieren kannst, sind letztendlich Aspekte des der Abrechnung und nicht der Funktion des Netzes, ja? Da kommt dann vielleicht nochmal sowas wie ich brauche nochmal eine zweite SIM-Karte, dann muss da ein Prozess angestoßen werden, aber du kannst eigentlich sagen, dass,
diese Webseite so gut wie keine Änderung an dem Netz vornimmt.
Wobei es könnte ja sein, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, von welcher Generation Mobilfunknetz man da jetzt ausgehen muss. Ich meine, wenn man an Afghanistan denk
dann glaubt man ja immer, das müsste irgendwie so Vorsteinzeit sein, aber tatsächlich sind ja eigentlich dort,
Also Mobilfunk spielt ja in unterentwickelten Ländern eine ganz andere Rolle und ist teilweise äh durchaus auch aufm aktuellen Stand und mag ja auch sein, dass es mittlerweile Systeme gibt
Also gleich nochmal was dazu sagen, die gerade so dieses Fragestellung, das haben wir ja hier auch. Ich möchte gerne an meinem Account bestimmte Dinge ändern, ich möchte gerne das Verhältnis ändern, Anrufbeantworter et cetera. Also es gibt schon so einen gewissen
Rückflussbedarf zu dem Mobilfunknetz und natürlich auch aktueller Einblick in die Kosten, insbesondere wenn auch Payment darüber realisiert wird.
Ja, aber die Information, wo sich Leute aufhalten, hat damit einfach nichts zu tun und ist eher in dem
in dem in dem Kernnetz angesiedelt, im AJL Aviel A und da hast du irgendwie einfach nicht was großartig.
Ja, in dem Location-Register.
Genau, du wirst nicht in du, also ich halte die Geschichte für äußerst unwahrscheinlich und,
zumindest in der Form, wie sie da erzählt wird, dass der Eintritt Eingangsfaktor ausgerechnet die Kundenwebsite gewesen sei. Interessant an diesem Punkt ist aber, dass wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass es jetzt ein ein Netzwerk gäbe, dass äh
so dramatisch schlecht konfiguriert ist,
Ähm dann könnte man davon ausgehen, dass es noch ganz andere Schwächen hat und auch über die habe ich hier auch schon öfter mal gesprochen, äh dass es eben allein mit der Mobilfunknummer in der Regel möglich ist, eine Person zu lokalisieren. Und das geht folgendermaßen
Ähm ich glaube, ich hab's hier schon mal erklärt, aber ich mach's einfach nochmal ganz kurz in sehr übersichtlich.
Ein Mobilfunknetz verweiß wo du bist, weil,
es nicht auf allen Antennen, die im Land verteilt sind, gleichzeitig nach dir suchen kann, wenn du einen Anruf bekommst. Das muss ja irgendwie die Last
verteilen, die Last der verteilten Menschen muss irgendwie auch auf diese Infrastruktur verteilt werden. Deswegen weiß, dass Mobilfunknetz ungefähr zu jedem Zeitpunkt, in welchem Bereich du bist. Diese Bereiche sind ein bisschen aufgetrennt quasi in so einer Art ähm.
Nennt man das wie so ein Astdiagramm, ne? Also es ist irgendwie von mir aus aufgeteilt in Nord und Süd und West und Ost und dann gibt's nochmal eben die Ballungszentren und da muss man sich das wie so ein, wie so ein Ast vorstellen,
und ähm so weiß das Mobilfunknetz bis zum gewissen Grad in welcher Region du bist und wenn es dann wirklich eine Interaktion herstellt, sogar sehr genau bis in welcher Zelle du bist. Und bei dieser Zelle, die die strahlt in drei Richtungen, da quasi dann auch noch in welche,
welche Richtung von dieser Zelle und dann auch noch mit welcher ähm Empfangs- und Sendeleistung du reinkommst, kann das Mobilfunknetz sich sehr genau lokalisieren,
Einer der uralten Angriffe, die ich hier auch schon öfter ähm beschrieben habe, ist es,
den Interconnect des Mobilfunknetzes auszunutzen. Also das ähm,
Die Verbindung von einem Mobilfunknetz zum anderen, wo nämlich ein schlecht konfiguriertes Mobilfunknetz darüber Auskunft gibt, in welcher Zelle
in welchem Bereich sich eine Person höh findet
Das, was man vor vielen Jahren machen konnte, in bei vielen Mobilfunknetzen ist letztendlich über den, über den Interconnect sagen, ey, guck mal, ich würde hier ganz gerne demo-Themen eine Mobilfunk äh eine SMS-Nachricht schicken.
Sag mir doch mal ganz kurz, an welchem MSC ich das abliefern muss und dann hat das Mobilfunknetz das über den Interconnect verraten. Dadurch konntest du zum Beispiel schon mal herausfinden, in welcher Region Deutschland sich
die Zielperson befindet. Durch weitere komplexere Tricks, die von Carsten Nohl und Tobias Engel beim.
Vorletzten Kongress auch präsentiert wurden,
konnte man auch sehr viel mehr herausfinden, aber so ein SS sieben Angriff ist sehr viel geeigneter, die den Aufenthaltsort einer Person herauszufinden. Ich habe jetzt mal gerade in den Forschungsdaten, die wir in den letzten Jahren zusammengetragen haben, geschaut, wir haben leider
keine Information über die Mobilfunkkonfiguration in Afghanistan, deswegen kann ich da jetzt nicht weiter drüber sprechen, aber wenn jemand
die die Location von Leuten herausfinden möchte, halte ich es für relativ unwahrscheinlich, dass der,
die erste Angriffsoberfläche und die wo man am Ende auch erfolgreich ist, ausgerechnet die Kundenwebseite sein wird.
Das kann aber natürlich trotzdem sein, aber mir kommt die Geschichte so noch ein bisschen,
komisch vor. Das nur am Rande interessant ist natürlich auch, dass die Bundeswehr hier offenbar äh in die kritische Infrastruktur,
Eines anderen Staates,
Ein eingegriffen hat und die verletzt hat und das zu einem Zeitpunkt, als wir öffentlich noch bei, bei weitem nicht so weit waren, zu sagen, wir wollen eine Offensive äh Betätigung der Bundeswehr haben,
im Bereich des Cybers.
Na ja, es ging ja nicht gegen den Staat, ging ja gegen den Terror. Ist ja was ganz anderes.
Ich kann mich da nur andere anschließen, der sagte, da muss man schon eine vernünftige Debatte drüber haben.
Ja, natürlich.
Wir bleiben mal kurz bei den Location-Daten von Mobilfunknetzen. Ähm.
Es gab nämlich auch jetzt endlich, das war seit längeren,
Längerem angefragt und ich weiß, es gab also Bestrebungen des NSA-Untersuchungsausschusses da einen eine Sachverständige Person zu finden von ähm,
die Auskunft darüber geben kann, ob sich denn die Daten über Mobilfunknetze eignen.
Für gezielte Tötungen mit Drohnen. Das ist ja eine Sache, die jetzt, sage ich mal, eigentlich komplett außer Frage steht,
es ist so, aber man brauchte quasi ein eine Sachverständige Auskunftsperson, die es einfach nochmal vernünftig zu Protokoll gibt für diesen NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss, weil ja die ganze Zeit behauptet wurde,
dies wäre nicht der Fall und da gab es dann jetzt ein äh,
ein äh Gutachten, was dann in den SR NSR-Untersuchungsausschuss eingebracht wurde und zwar von Professor Hannes Federat der,
in ähm Fachbereich Informatik der Universität Hamburg tätig ist und als Vizepräsident der Gesellschaft für Informatik,
sich engagiert und äh in seinem Gutachten,
Beantwortet er vier Fragen des äh Untersuchungsausschusses, nämlich welche Daten sind dafür geeignet? Ähm,
Unter den jeweils im Untersuchungszeitraumgebet gegebenen technischen Möglichkeiten Personen in Regionen zu lokalisieren?
Und eine Tötung mittelstrone durchzuführen, also welche Daten sind prinzipiell dafür geeignet,
Wie funktionieren die die technischen Methoden,
Ähm welche Genauigkeit äh ergibt sich bei diesen technischen Methoden ähm.
Und ist eine und oder Insi Identifizierung als einziges technisches Datum mittelbar oder unmittelbar ausreichend.
Hintergrund ist, dass der BND ja diese Daten weitergegeben hat an die USA,
Und seine Antwort ist.
Ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr ins Detail gehen, weil ich immer wieder dann das Feedback bekomme, dass sie, dass einige der Hörenden hier nicht mehr folgen können, aber wir machen sie mal ein bisschen übersichtlich. Es gibt also eine Telefonnummer, das ist die MSISDN.
Dann gibt es die Imsi, das ist die International Mobile Subscriber Identity, das ist quasi die im Mobilfunknetz oder den Mobilfunknetzen interne Identität, die man dort hat, dann hat das ähm,
das äh Telefongerät auch nochmal eine E-Mail International Mobile Equipment Identity, die sind alle immer Unique. Dann gibt's noch die Seriennummer ISN und den Mobile Equipment Identifier,
und verschiedene weitere Aspekte wie jetzt so eine Mac Adresse, die ihr im WLAN, ne? Was eine Rolle spielt.
Kurz, wie geht das, wenn ich jetzt mit meiner Drohne, ich habe hier auch so eine kleine Paritrone, wenn ich jetzt mit dieser Drohne sage, ich möchte den Tim töten,
dann habe ich ja seine Telefonnummer und dann würde ich's zum Beispiel den gerade beschriebenen Hack erstmal machen und über das Mobilfunknetz anfragen,
in welchem Land Tim sich denn gerade aufhält? Das kann ich ja äh relativ einfach,
dann tun, da bekomme ich auch heute noch bei den meisten Mobilfunknetzen zumindest die eine Antwort, die darauf schließen lässt, ob diese Person sich im Heimatland befindet oder nicht,
Wenn ich jetzt Zugriff habe auf das Mobilfunknetz kann ich sogar genauer herausfinden oder ein schlechter, konfiguriertes Mobilfunknetz habe, kann ich sogar sehr genau herausfinden, ob sich Tim zum Beispiel in Berlin aufhält, bei Berlin könnte man das dann so runterbrechen auf äh fünf Regionen ungefähr
und dann wüsste ich schon mal, ob ich hier in Ost oder in Westberlin im Norden oder im Süden suchen muss und dann fliege ich mit mit meiner Drohne über Berlin,
Muss ich jetzt mit meiner Drohne natürlich sehr schnell machen, weil die nur zehn Minuten Nako-Laufzeit hat. Aber das kriege ich ja hin, dann fliege ich über Berlin und habe an Bord dieser Drohne einen Imsi-Ketchup. Und dieser Imsi-Ketchu,
ähm out imitiert automatisch die Mobilfunkzellen, die so drum herum die über die ihr gerade fliegt und hat einen.
Als wäre er das jeweilige Mobilfunknetz.
Er tut so, als wäre er das Mobilfunknetz dein Mobilfunknetz kenne ich ja in dem Fall sogar schon. Ähm aber man könnte es natürlich auch auf weitere,
äh auf auf alle Mobilfunknetze ausweiten. Vielleicht suche ich ja gleichzeitig auch den Holgi. Ähm.
Nimm Holgi, nimm dich mit.
Kommt drauf an, wen ich eher finde. Ähm dann habe ich also imitiere ich die Mobilfunknetze,
Und was dann passiert ist, dass sich die Mobilfittelefone, die ich catche, also bei mir anmelden und im Zuge dieser Anmeldung frage ich sie nach ihrer IMEI und ihrer Imsy,
Und in dem Fall, wenn sie dann nicht die den Werten entsprechen, die ich suche, dann sage ich denen einfach, dich akzeptiere ich nicht, gehe bitte zu einer anderen Zelle. Und wenn ich dich erwische, Tim, dann sage ich, oh, alles klar,
Und dann sorge ich dafür, dass wir einen konstanten,
da Sendefluss zwischen uns beiden haben, das kann ich zum Beispiel durch eine Silent SMS oder ein Silent Call machen. Dadurch sorge ich dafür, dass dein Mobiltelefon konstant,
an meine Zelle sendet? Oder überhaupt konstant ein Funksignal imitiert,
Und jetzt fliege ich mit meiner Drohne im Kreisen um dich herum und kann ja dann durch die Empfangsleistung,
sehen, ob ich mich von dir entferne oder zu dir hinbewege, bis ich dich dann irgendwann nach zwei Kreisen oder so klar lokalisiert habe und weiß, wohin ich meine Wasserbombe,
werfen muss. Und dann treffe ich dich und dann habe ich dich,
Im Prinzip, egal wo auf der Welt du dich befunden hast, ähm mit Hilfe des Mobilfunknetzes bis auf den letzten Meter lokalisieren können.
Im Prinzip muss man sich klar machen, so ein Telefon ist einfach ein Peilsender.
Eigentlich ja in gewisser ja kann man so machen. Ich ich wehre mich ja so ein bisschen gegen diese abgedroschenen Begriffe. Das ist ja auch keine Datenkrake und Peilsender und Ortungswanze und was nicht alles. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein Gerät.
Funktioniert es wie einer.
Man kann es dazu bringen.
Man kann es dazu ja genau.
Du also es ist auf jeden Fall unmöglich mit einem solchen
Ding in der Tasche rumzurennen und davon auszugehen, dass das keiner orden könnte. Ähm das ist ein sehr wichtiges Gutachten, was hier stattgefunden hat, weil dieser Zusammenhang, dass das möglich wäre, wie gesagt, der ist für
sachkundige völlig offensichtlich und es ist auch eines der schlecht gehütet Geheimnisse, dass das auch genauso stattfindet
Aber es ist für den Untersuchungsausschuss eben von fundamentaler Bedeutung, dass jemand mit äh mit mit äh Ruf und Sachverstand diese Zusammenhänge erklärt und eben damit auch,
zu Protokoll gibt die Daten, die ihr da ausgetauscht habt,
sind verwendbar für extra legale Tötungen durch ein äh durch den Staat oder durch durch das Militär der USA in einem Land, in dem sie,
indem sie kein Urteil oder sonst was versprechen. Das ist eine entscheidende Frage für diesen NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss und,
in Bezug auf diese Frage kommt dieser Sachverständigenauskunft eben eine sehr besondere Bedeutung zu.
Sollen wir mal zu so einer, wo ich fast dachte, wäre eine gute Nachricht? Oder noch ein bisschen schlechte Nachricht.
Ähm fast eine gute Nachricht.
Fast eine gute Nachricht. Fast eine gute Nachricht, die äh welches Ministerium, was das Bundesministerium für Bildung und Forschung hat eine Open Access Strategie veröffentlicht. Und denkst, wow,
jetzt geht's endlich mal in Richtung Open Access. Wir erinnern uns das Gegenteil von Open Access ist die aktuelle ähm Realität im,
wissenschaftlichen Publikationswesen und das funktioniert so. Der Steuerzahler bezahlt die Universitäten, um Dinge zu erforschen.
Die Universitäten publizieren das, kriegen kein Geld dafür. Und die Verlage, die das publizieren nehmen dann wieder Geld von den Universitäten dafür, dass sie ihre eigene Forschung in diesem Magazin lesen dürfen.
Ja, so läuft das genial. Auf so eine Idee musst du erstmal kommen, ne? Und,
die die wie gesagt die Dienstleistung, die dieser Verlag, äh, die die Verlage an der Öffentlichkeit erbringen, Grenz gegen null, denn der einzige Mehrwert, den sie bieten, ist, dass sie eben dieses,
durchführen lassen. Das machen aber auch in der Regel Leute, die nicht dafür bezahlt werden. Das ist ein ein
ein einziger, ein einziges äh ein einziger,
ekelhafter Pilz, äh der diese gesamte äh Kultur befallen hat und von der von dem zu befreien, die Wissenschaft leider sich nicht in der Lage ist, zumindest man hat immer.
Manche wollen das aber das Problem ist natürlich, dass die Leute, die bisher von dem System profitiert haben natürlich wenig Interesse daran haben, dass es sich ändert. Wie das eben so oft ist mit Änderungen, gesellschaftlichen Änderungen,
Ich denke, dass a,
nichts dran vorbeigeht, solche Open Excess äh Prinzipien auch festzuetablieren, aber da sind wir noch nicht so ganz. Aber es zeichnet sich zumindest ab, dass dieser Begriff so eine gewisse,
Luftraumhoheit gewinnt in der Debatte.
So, dann habe ich irgendwie gedacht, ach wunderbar, jetzt dann klickst du doch mal drauf. Wenn alle sagen, es gibt jetzt die Open Access in Deutschland, Strategie des Bundesministeriums für Bildung und Forschung,
Die erstreckt sich über über dreizehn Seiten und dann denkst du, boah, wow, so, dann lassen wir mal gucken, wie was habt ihr denn jetzt vor, ne? Welche Anreize wollt ihr schaffen, damit sich hier
etwas ändert. Und dann habe ich dieses Ding gesehen. Ich dachte, sie waren ich dachte, es wäre ein Scherz, ich dachte erst, ich hätte jetzt irgendwie falsch geklickt. Es findet sich darin, nicht,
eine eine einzige konkrete Maßnahme.
Also da steht dann irgendwie sowas drin wie Open Access in die BMBF Förderung integrieren. Das ist schön, das heißt mit anderen Worten, wenn du von denen Förderung bekommst, werden sie sagen, dann musst du,
Das auch in Ropen Excess publizieren. Das ist zu äh durchaus zu begrüßen. Gleichzeitig sagen sie, sie,
errichten ein Post Grand Fund.
Wo sie Open Excess Publikationskosten übernehmen. Das ist ganz interessant, das hörst du bei unseren Freunden von Methodisch Incorrect häufiger, dass die Uni quasi draufzahlen muss,
damit ihre Publikation in Open Access erscheint. Und das Bundesministerium für Forschung,
und Wissenschaftler, was auch immer, die hier sich auf die Fahne geschrieben haben, sagen, na wenn das so ist, na dann werfen wir da halt Geld drauf. Statt zu sagen.
Wir nehmen's einfach mal, ja, uns einfach frei für dich.
Das ist also also als wenn es heute, also wir sitzen hier zwanzigsechzehn und die Leute machen sich Gedanken darüber,
Äh wie sie denn in der Lage sein könnten, etwas einfach mal im Internet kostenlos zur Verfügung zu stellen,
Das ist also wirklich ein ein Witz vor dem Herrn. Ähm aber immerhin äh ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung. Ich erkenne da nur keine einzige Maßnahme, die jetzt mal geeignet ist, einen zentralen Umschwung herbeizuführen.
Das von der deutschen Forschung, Forschungsgemeinschaft geförderte Projekt Open Access Punkt Net bietet praktische Hilfestellungen und Informationen für einen zielgruppenorientierten Einstieg in das Thema Open Access,
Der große Erfolg dieses Projektes, ich hatte noch nie von gehört äh zeigt, dass es einen breiten Beratungs und Aufklärungsbedarf auf allen Ebenen gibt,
Wollt ihr, ich meine, die, die Universitäten klagen seit jeher über diese Probleme mit den mit den Verlagen. Ich glaube nicht, dass es da einen zentralen Aufklärungsbedarf gibt.
Na ja, also das einzige, was ich hier sehe, ist, dass die äh dass sie angekündigt haben.
Ja, dass die steuerlich geförderten Forschungsergebnisse ähm eben nicht mehr in
kommerziellen und geschlossenen Publikationen veröffentlicht werden sollen, aber das Ministerium betont direkt, die Forscher können natürlich auch künftig frei entscheiden, ob und in welcher Zeitschrift sie publizieren wollen. Mit anderen Worten, wir machen gar nichts,
ja? Also es ist wirklich äh wirklich bedauerlich. Bedauerlich, bedauerlich, bedauerlich, bedauerlich.
Tschau. Also wie gesagt, man kann sich natürlich jetzt bei solchen Strategiepapern schön ähm
ähm darüber aufregen, dass sie nicht konkret sind, aber ich finde allein die Tatsache, dass dass diese PayPal schon mal existieren und damit auch die Bestrebungen insbesondere der wissenschaftlichen Gruppierung, also Helmold Stiftung, äh et cetera, ähm,
Helmutsgemeinschaft und andere, dass dass diese Trends sozusagen aufgenommen werden und eben damit auch im Prinzip politisches äh Gehör finden.
Ja
Wir kommen nochmal zur Handy-Location-Daten vor einigen, ich glaube, es ist auch schon wieder zwei, drei Jahre her, da hatte O2 angekündigt, dass sie äh also Telefonica Deutschland angekündigt, dass sie,
Die Location-Daten ihrer Kunden gerne monetarisieren wollen. Damals haben sie äh starke Proteste von Datenschützern und Verbraucherschützern bekommen und haben diese Geschäftsidee zurückgezogen,
Jetzt haben sie bekannt gegeben. Ah äh wir haben uns das anders überlegt. Äh wir haben gelernt, Datenschutz ist ein kritischer Punkt und deswegen äh machen wir das jetzt. Machen sie es trotzdem. Ähm.
Und wollen dann zum Beispiel äh eine Handelskette,
äh irgendwie ein mit einer Handelskette sprechen, um ihr zu helfen Kundenströme durch das Einkaufszentrum zu identifizieren. Äh es gibt natürlich dann dieses andere Idee, ähm.
Den anderen Gedanken äh Staus vorherzusagen und so. Also die werden jetzt die die großen Ströme Bewegungsströme in ihrem neuen, doppelt so großen Netz ähm als.
Als Informa auf, als käufliche Information zur Verfügung stellen. Da weiß man doch äh.
Ton, dass ihnen der Datenschutz doch sehr am Herzen liegt.
Ja, das musst du immer machen, wenn du das äh Google sagt dir, Facebook sagt dir, dass ihnen Datenschutz am Herzen liegt.
Alle sagen Datenschutz am Herzen liegen, weil wenn du das nicht sagst, bist du sowieso schon mal raus aus dem Spiel.
Zweitens, wenn es sind ja auch deine Daten, mit denen du Geld verdienen möchtest, natürlich möchtest du, dass sie bei dir bleiben und die Daten geschützt sind, sonst hast du ja kein äh sonst hast du ja kein Geschäftsmodell.
Man muss dazu sagen, dass natürlich Mobilfunkunternehmen schon lange Geld mit diesen Bewegungsdaten verdienen, das ist ja überhaupt keine Neuigkeit, äh voll anonymisierte Daten, wenn zum Beispiel für die Verkehrs äh Berichterstattung, also,
in äh also in Echtzeit
also ganz am Anfang war es so, dass man die Daten genommen hat und offline durchgerechnet hat, um Modelle zu erstellen, wie schnell bestimmte Straßen sind, ne? Weil die trecken halt die Leute quasi mit ihren äh Telefonen auf dem,
im Auto,
und haben daraus entsprechende Bewegungsmuster gemacht, das war halt am Anfang noch äh so rechten intensiv, dass man das eben nicht in Echtzeit machen konnte. Mittlerweile ist das alles in Echtzeit, also wenn heute auf Google Maps oder Apple Maps
ein Stau irgendwo angezeigt wird, dann ist,
das sehr wahrscheinlich, dass diese Wahrnehmung übers Mobilfunknetz gekommen ist, beziehungsweise mittlerweile natürlich auch über die individuelle Rückmeldung der Telefone selbst über das Netz, ne? Also diese mehr oder weniger anonyme in Anführungsstrichen, Rückmeldungen der Telefone
zu ihren Clouds, äh, wo sie sich quasi befinden, welcher Geschwindigkeit sie sich gerade irgendwohin bewegen. Und ähm
Das ist schon immer eine Dienstleistung gewesen und jetzt würden sie halt gerne noch einen Schritt weitergehen, dass eben so ähm etwas persönlicher werden lassen.
Na wenn er also das die Telefone verraten, dass net.
Die Telefone verraten ihre ihren Standort ja eher dann halt Google, Maps oder so, ne? Also das mal was gibt's ja auch nochmal auf App Basis, sagen es halt Google oder Apple
Aber hier ist also jemand, der sagt, unabhängig davon, was
für eine App auf dem Gerät läuft, ja? Ob's überhaupt ein Smartphone ist. Wir analysieren jetzt halt die Bewegungsströme unserer Kunden,
Und da kommt natürlich, das heißt, wenn du die analysierst, das heißt, du sammelst die auch, das ist nicht notwendigerweise äh etwas, was,
du tatsächlich gemacht hast, was du
konntest oder was was notwendigerweise du erfasst hast, ist, welche Zelle ist, wann, wie ausgelastet, aber ein Nutzer tatsächlich durch die Zellen zu verfolgen, ist etwas, was keine Standardfunktion von Mobilfunknetzen ist. Das musst du dann schon.
Explizit einrichten, zu sagen, ich möchte quasi die History haben, wieder sich bewegt hat oder sogar eine äh eine Datenauswertung machen, die mir live zeigt, wie Leute sich bewegen
Ja? Du konntest zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt in solche Daten schaust, natürlich konntest du sehen, dass am Samstagmittag die ganzen Zellen bei dem Fußballstadion ähm.
Proppevoll sind und dass sich dann irgendwie, wenn das Fußballspiel vorbei ist in alle Richtungen quasi eine Auslastungswelle,
verliert, ja? Aber es ist etwas anderes als zu sagen, wir wissen, dass die Leute, die aus Kreuzberg, Friedrichshain, zum Stadion kommen, über die es drei fahren
Und dass die Leute, die aus Charlottenburg kommen, äh, übern über die Autobahn mit dem Ring fahren oder so, ne? Also das ist eine andere, eine andere äh Detailanalyse,
die hier.
Eine fortgeschrittene Analyse, aber ich würde überhaupt nicht ausschließen, dass auch das äh zunehmende Maße eine Rolle äh spielt, auch explizit für die Verkehrsvorhersage, um zum Beispiel auch
Umleitungen schnell zu erkennen, ne? Wo du sozusagen mehr als nur die Aktivität an einer Zelle äh bekommen musst, sondern wo du einerseits straßengenau und andererseits eben auch vielleicht über einen längeren Zeitraum hinweg äh eine,
eine Entität verfolgen muss, allein nur um sie,
danach der KI zu übergeben, damit die sozusagen aus diesen ganzen Strategien einen Schluss zieht.
Richtig und damit kannst
Geld verdienen und das machen die jetzt. Also herzlichen Glückwunsch zu einem Mobilfunkanbieter, der macht genau das, was Tim gerade gesagt hat, der verfolgt eure Bewegungen über den Tag und führt diese einer künstlichen Intelligenz zu,
lässt daraus Geld drucken und die Erkenntnisse durch die Erkenntnisse, die damit gewonnen wurden. Da zahlt man doch gerne seine Rechnung. Aber macht euch keine Sorgen. Demnächst kriegt ihr wahrscheinlich gar keine Rechnungen mehr. Ihr seid da nur verpflichtet dieses Telefon immer bei euch zu haben und wenn ihr sagt, okay, oh to, dann antwortet euch das Telefon auch
und bestellt euch das bei Amazon, äh was ihr schon immer nicht haben wolltet.
Gut, das Ganze bringt uns jetzt zu den Terminen.
Am Samstag, den vierundzwanzigsten September um dreizehn Uhr siebenunddreißig eröffnet Schwerins erster Hackspace. Da gibt es eine Menge an Attraktionen für euch. Ihr könnt Tick Tacto gegen einen Industrieroboter spielen, Hacker Japper D und
Schlösser knacken.
In äh Wien gibt's auch was Schönes, nämlich die Privacy Week organisiert vom Chaoscomputerclub in Wien findet statt
vom vierundzwanzigsten bis zum dreißigsten zehnten zweitausendundsechzehn
fällt damit auch ein bisschen auch auf Lokbuch Netzpolitik zweihundert. Wer keine Lust hat nach Berlin zu kommen oder keine Möglichkeit hat, dort wird's wahrscheinlich auch eine Live-Übertragung geben irgendwo. Äh Informationen zu den zahlreichen Veranstaltungen an verschiedenen Orten in der Stadt gibt's unter Privacy Week
Punkt AT.
Und es war abzusehen, wenn wir hier einmal anfangen, Chaostress bekannt zu machen, dann melden sich natürlich auch noch andere, wie zum Beispiel der Chaostreff Flensburg. In unserem Raum Space, den wir mit dem Phänomena EV betreiben, steht moderne Technik zum Kennenlernen und Ausprobieren bereit werden wir in Kenntnis gesetzt
dort kann man einfach mal vorbeischauen, egal was einen interessiert, dienstags ab neunzehn Uhr gegenüber der Phänomenta im Raum Space.
Ja und das äh heißt ähm wir befinden uns wieder am Ende der Sendung.
Ja
Gibt's noch was nachzutragen? Zweihundert. Hatten wir schon erwähnt.
Blockbodenticket zweihundert. Haben wir erwähnt gehabt? Das wird ein großes Spiel, ey, das wird ein schöner Spaß. Meinst du.
Wir werden uns überarbeiten. Ja, wie immer.
Ich habe so ein bisschen, ich habe tatsächlich so ein bisschen Angst, ja.
Ja, klar, so wie du das jetzt hier aufbaust und in höchsten Tönen lobst und Großartigkeiten voraussagst, der alle total pumpt. Komm da rein und dann so, äh,
Dort Veranstaltung. Ja, mal gucken. Wir wollen uns ein bisschen was einfallen lassen, aber.
Das werdet ihr dann alle sehen.
Vor allem, also das eigentlich ist, was das wirklich anstrengende wird ja sein,
Damit die Veranstaltung so richtig abgeht, brauchen wir gute Neuigkeiten.
Gute Neuigkeiten.
Ich meine, ist alles mögliche. Ich weiß, eine ganze Menge lässt sich mit Geld erreichen, ne. So kann schön Raum mieten, kannste Leute einladen, ne.
Ich dachte du wolltest jetzt die Politik bestechen.
Genau, das wird teuer. So und das schlagen wir natürlich auf die Ticketpreise drauf. Könnt ihr euch überlegen. Wollt ihr gute Nachrichten?
Dann wird's teuer.
Wird teuer.
Für dich gibt's nur Depressionen.
Ich denke mal, wir werden auch nicht unbedingt jetzt so eine nachrichtenlastige äh ein Event draus äh machen, sondern ohnehin ein wenig mehr in die Zeit äh blicken, sowohl nach hinten als auch nach vorne.
Ja, aber das will man dann alles sehen. Noch haben wir kein, kein festes Programm, noch sind wir auch für Ideen äh äh offen. Bisher ist noch nicht.
Es wurden doch es sind schon welche eingegangen, habe.
Ist schon was reingekommen, was was ich noch so ein bisschen vermisst habe, also eine Arbeit, die man sich selber,
wirklich kaum machen will, wenn man nicht von vornherein schon immer drauf geachtet hätte, wäre so,
Das sind so so Best-of äh Collagen. Das muss jetzt nicht unbedingt so ein totaler Bringer sein, aber keine Ahnung, vielleicht gibt's da irgendjemand da draußen, der so interessante Stellen ähm,
zweihundert Jahren Lokbuchnetzpolitik zusammen.
Tausendjährige Podcast.
Ja? Also so paar Zeitmarken oder so werden da schon mal ganz interessant, weiß ich eben nicht. So, Dinge, die vielleicht besonders gut oder albern gelaufen sind, äh sonstige Highlights,
oder auch Loadlights keine Ahnung, vielleicht kriegt man sowas dann auch noch verwurstelt.
Zweihundert Folgen Lokbuchnetzpolitik, Höhen und Tiefen. Gute Zeiten, schlechte Zeiten.
Höhen und Tiefen. Ja.
Das wäre sehr schön.
So wie es beim Union-Jubiläum hieß, irgendwie, wir hatten wir hatten Höhen und viele Tiefen. Aber wir sind immer wieder siegreich hervorgegangen.
Was ist das für ein Podcast? Hm.
Union? Das ist eine Mannschaf.
So ein Zweitliga-Podcast eher, ne? Nicht so in unserer Liga hier. Dritte.
Ja, es ist ähm jetzt glaube ich nicht der Raum, um Fußball zu diskutieren.
Richtig Tim, es ist nämlich Lokbuch Netzpolitik, das hast du richtig erkannt. Deswegen gehen wir jetzt gekonnt über.
Aber ohne Fußballbezug ist ja nichts. Und an dem Tag ist auch Heimspiel, also es wird für mich eh schwierig. Vielleicht vielleicht habe ich auch vielleicht habe ich gar keine Zeit. Ich ich muss noch Stadion, Alter.
Das wäre natürlich sehr schade wenn der Tim im Stadion wäre.
Ist ja tagsüber. Wir machen ja in die Nacht.
Deswegen sperrst du dich so dagegen, dass wir das im Olympiastadion machen.
Bist zu weit.
Ja, aber diese alte Försterei ist ein bisschen klein.
Neuer zwanzigtausend.
Ja und der Rest.
Na ja, wir verabschieden uns mit Linus, der immer noch denkt, das Olympiastadion lege in Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg. Ja, hast du jetzt auch einen gesehen, ne? Jetzt finde dich mal raus.
Nee, das liegt nicht in Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg. Das wird da hinverlegt. Ich will dich mal raus. Die Busse, die Busse fahren nach Friedrichshain Kreuzberg.
Die Busse. Sonderzüge.
Die Sonne, die Sonder-S-Bahn.
Schluss hier mit dem Irrsinn. Wir sagen tschüss.
Danke an Conny und Ambro.
Und alle anderen die Blog Buchnes Politik und die Mieterebene regelmäßig unterstützen. Wir sagen tschüss bis bald bis nächste Woche. Ciao ciao.
Ciao ciao.